cuatro años después del incendio nodam
sigue rodeada de andamios y grúas
mientras las obras de restauración
iniciando una fase crítica la
reconstrucción de la aguja
es una réplica exacta de la que
construye el arquitecto del siglo 19 los
carpinteros tendrán que trabajar a más
de 60 metros de altura y solo la base de
esta aguja el taburete pesa 80 toneladas
y esto es solo el principio del
verdadero desafío técnico una enorme
andamio se elevará desde el suelo de la
Catedral a 100 metros de altura la
altura de la aguja y el andamio
acompañará el montaje de la aguja y a
partir de finales del año de 2023
empezaremos a cubrir la aguja y el
andamio irá bajando a medida que se vaya
completando la cobertura
en el interior es casi imposible
distinguir Los pilares o las paredes de
la Catedral
los andamios están por todas partes Es
un verdadero Laberinto en el que es a
veces difícil orientarse
de repente un espacio abierto nos
permite vislumbrar el aspecto que tendrá
la catedral una vez finalizada su
restauración
[Música]
algunas partes de la Catedral han sido
restauradas para alcanzar una blancura
desconocida los asistentes que visitarán
la catedral podrán entrar en poco más de
un año descubrirán una catedral
magnificada por sus trabajos de limpieza
y restauración y la descubrirán como
nunca se ha visto en la memoria de
nuestros contemporáneos
un verdadero
renacimiento para la catedral cuyo
reapertura cuya reapertura al público
está previsto para diciembre 2024 la
catedral no estará lista para los Juegos
Olímpicos de París como inicialmente
previsto pero esa reapertura sigue
siendo un reto enorme sobre todo para
las doscientas empresas que trabajan A
toda máquina para hacer posible esta
restauración de la catedral